Our current power grid is basically a giant
firehose of electricity going from power plants
to your house.
But what if it were efficient, two-way, and
let you use your neighbor's solar panels?
That's the SMART GRID!
Sup guys, Trace here.
In 2003, a tree limb touched a high-voltage
power line in Ohio causing a cascading blackout
that stretched across the northeast from New
York to Chicago and as far north as Ottawa,
Canada.
50 million people were without power for as
long as two days.
The estimated cost: six billion dollars and
11 lives.
You could blame the tree branch, the people
in Ohio who should have trimmed it, or even
the faulty alarm system, but really we should
blame ourselves.
The North American power grid is… well it's
a mess.
In 1882, Thomas Edison built the first commercial
power grid in New York City, introducing the
idea of electricity distribution.
Now, almost 140 years later, it's been built
ad-hoc... jury-rigged into two major grids:
the Eastern and Western Interconnection, and
three minor grids: Texas, Alaska, and Quebec
Interconnections.
Together they comprise 1 TRILLION dollars
of hard work for public and private groups,
all to provide power to the U.S. and Canada.
And it's dumb.
Right now, our power grid provides 830 gigawatts
of electricity to more than 330 million people,
and yet, there's no storage system.
Dumb.
If you flip on your lightswitch, the local
power plant has to ramp up production, just
a bit, to power that light.
Also, all the power flows one way, from generators,
to stations, to your house, like an electricity
firehose.
Dumb.
If something breaks, they can't just run power
around the problem, they have to drive out,
find it, and fix it.
Things like this are immensely frustrating
for utilities, regulators, governments, and
you and me.
Which is why we need a smart grid.
A smart grid is to the current dumb grid as
the newest smartphone is to Zach Morris' massive
beige brick-thing.
Actually, no.
Zack's phone was still sweet.
Our grid is not.
The smart grid basically adds internet-connected
computers to the mix.
The utility company sends power AND information
to the houses, and then the houses send info
back to tell it how it's doing, how much it's
using and also where the power is coming from.
On top of that, if you have solar power on
your roof, or wind power or whatever… and
the power goes out, the grid will know you're
okay, and even ask you to help power homes
and facilities nearby -- like traffic lights
or emergency services!
Computers at every point on the grid would
know where they are in relation to privately-owned
home batteries or solar panels, and they'd
be able to communicate with them too!
This internet-connected grid could revolutionize
how power is generated and distributed and
make the whole trillion-dollar mess more efficient.
Right now, 6.1 percent of all power is lost
as the electricity physically runs through
the lines, heating them up and generating
noise.
That's about 19-and-a-half BILLION dollars
disappearing just from lines themselves.
With computers talking back and forth to the
utilities everyone would know second-by-second
to only route power as needed… perhaps from
local storage or solar: rather than burning
coal far away because one guy is watching
TV.
It might seem obvious, but this means good
things for companies, people, even the environment.
For example, if the grid knew there were batteries
available, the power plants wouldn't need
to burn as much coal.
Or, if the grid knew it was windy or sunny,
it could pull from the local renewable farms!
You could even, as a consumer, CHOOSE to only
use power from local storage or charge your
car when the cost was lower.
Honestly, it sounds like a crazy nerdy dream.
Which is sort of where we are now…
Countries all over the world are trying to
get their citizens excited about this new
smart infrastructure, but it's hard, and expensive.
Ultimately, the smart grid will save money,
but it will also help us use distributed power
generation, and help the environment by eliminating
waste and encouraging people to understand
more about how they're using their own electricity.
Go Planet!
Sponsor?
If you're coming out of this thinking, wait,
but if the grid is so crazy NOW, how does
it even work?
You're in luck, my friend!
Remember that blackout during the Superbowl?
We looked into how the power grid worked after
that!
Check it out!
Do you want to put solar panels on your roof?
Get a battery for your house?
Only use renewables?
Really into coal?